بعد مواسم الامطار يكون التوقيت السنوي
لانتشار حمى الضنك في مخيمات النازحين
بمارب قد بدا فعليا بالظهور الوباء
ظهر هذا العام سريع الانتشار محطما
الارقام السنويه المسجله في المشافي
الحكوميه
المخيم كامل امراض
تروح البيوت عاد فيها امراض عظم من
المستشفى بلغ عدد الحالات الى امس 71 حاله
مصابين بحمى الضنك هذا بسبب المستنقعات
المائيه الموجوده اضافه الى طفح بيارات
الصرف الصحي والى سائله الموجوده هنا
امامكم التي ممتلئه بالقمامه نساء واطفال
واسر بكاملها تتردد على مستشفى الوحده
بمنطقه الحصون شرقي المدينه بحثا عن
العلاج يقدم لهم المستشفى خدماته
بامكانياته وكادر محدود بعد اصابه خمسه
وسبعين في المئه من العاملين الصحيين فيه
بحمى الضنك
انتشر بشكل كبير ومخيف حيث اصبحنا في
مستشفى واحده بالحصول نستقبل اعداد هائله
من المرضى ما يقدر ب 15 حاله الى عشرين
حاله في اليوم في عشر ايام الاخيره
استقبلنا من قرب 95 حاله مستشفى الحصول
كادرها اصيب اصيب بنسبه 75%
السلطات الصحيه بمئرب بدات خطوات توعويه
لمحاصره الوباء اضافه الى نزول الفرق
الميدانيه في مناطق الانتشار بهدف تكثيف
التوعيه بضروره التخلص من المياه الراكده
والخزانات المكشوفه وكل مصادر البعوض
الناقل لحمى الضنك اوجدنا فرق الميدان من
متطوعات وعاملين صحيين للتثقيف في
المديريه وايضا في منطقه الحصون بالاخص
وايضا ان شاء الله في حمله ستقام به حمله
الرش الضبابي مع غياب الوعي الصحي وسوء
الخدمات ومكان الماوى تتضاعف معاناه
النازحين سنويا مع حمضنك في كل مخيمات
النازحين تنتشر حمى الضنك وفي المخيمات
القريبه من مرور مياه قنوات الري تتزايد
هذه الحالات في ظل وضع صحي كارثي محمود
الحميدي العربيه مارب
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات